[Music]
tonight in tel aviv images that change
everything in an escalation that has
already spiraled so fast
israel's missile defense systems
lighting up the sky as they try to
intercept
incoming hamas rockets
130 of them were fired from gaza in one
barrage
flights at the international airport
were urgently suspended and diverted
hamas said it was a specific target
and on the streets injured israelis
which for israel
will move this conflict onto a different
level
the earlier israeli assault on gaza
which prompted the hamas retaliation
had been relentless and for those who
are not the targets
but who are so often the victims it is
terrifying
with the weight of the israeli air force
on top of them there is
nowhere safe to run
locals filmed the moment a 13-story
building collapsed
it's not clear how many people were in
it at the time it is a residential block
the israelis had earlier said that they
were targeting militants in their homes
the number confirmed to have died
through the day and the night before
continues to rise
children too here a mother and her son
are buried
they're from a refugee camp most in gaza
are refugees
and in one of the hospitals agony and
defiance
this man vows revenge for the death of
his comrade a member of hamas's
jerusalem brigade
on the israeli side of the fence which
locks gaza off
in the city of ashkelon the air raid
sirens sounded through the day
in the skies the trails of israel's iron
dome missile defense system
it shot down most of the hamas rockets
the israeli communities here are used to
attacks from gaza
but not this many in just a few hours
this is the third time it's happened
since we've been here uh
you hear the uh the whale of the sirens
and then moments later
uh sometimes the thud of the rockets is
they
they come in from gaza there have been
scores of rockets over the course of the
past few hours most of them
hitting here around this town
amala wade the home of an elderly lady
and her carer
they both died unable to get to the
shelter in time
the israeli defense forces spokesman was
here keen to show us what israel faces
from hamas
no one can look at this and see anything
other than
a tragedy that has happened here um but
the
images that are coming out of gaza are
truly horrific
it seems that what israel is doing in
gaza is totally disproportionate to what
is happening here
i would beg to differ i think that what
we are doing are specific
strikes against military targets inside
gaza that are part of the
hamas and the islamic jihad military
infrastructure
we watched the iron dome intercept some
of them as they flew north let's go in
let's go in
come on mohammed hamas claims to be the
defender of the palestinian cause
striking their occupier israel will
strike back harder still
and the diplomacy to break this cycle
isn't there